we have had this segment on the Friday
show for the David Pakman show called
audience questions for years we actually
started doing audience questions before
we had the technology to take live calls
so now we take live calls and hear from
from people about what's on their mind
before we could take live calls we used
to collect questions from the audience
during the week and then answer three of
those questions on Friday we now have
live calls and increasingly I have
started to feel that they are sort of
redundant segments if we're taking live
calls and hearing from the audience and
hearing about what's on people's minds
do we then also need to do three
additional audience questions which are
basically just a different format of
live call so what I'm proposing to you
today and and I want your help with this
is that I'm looking at retiring audience
questions as a standalone segment
because we've got live calls and
replacing audience questions with
something else my question to you is
what do we replace audience questions
with I have a few ideas but I want to
hear from you about what what you would
like us to do number one right now we
alternate between doing a classic
interview from the archives that's
relevant today with a new commentary
that I do when we when we rerun the
interview we alternate that with doing a
few extra live calls every other week so
one thing we could do is we could get
rid of audience questions we could
continue doing the live calls but we
could do a classic interview every week
so instead of getting a classic
interview only every other week you get
a classic interview every week we have
more than enough interviews in the
archives and it would be no problem to
do that that's one possibility another
possibility is to replace live calls
with international news a sort of
international news wrap-up of the week
these tend not to do super well the
people who like the international news
segments really like them but overall I
don't know how appealing it is to the
majority of our audience that doesn't
mean we can't do it we could do segments
that appeal to you know a niche of the
audience that's
Science and Technology doing something
science and technology related every
week in place of audience questions
that's a possibility but these are only
like three ideas so what I'm asking you
to think about and get in touch with me
david at david pakman.com if you have
strong feelings what else might you like
to see taking the place of audience
questions the top suggestions that we
get we will turn into a poll open it up
to the entire audience and then you will
ultimately decide what's going to
replace audience questions get in touch
I'm open to all ideas there's no such
thing as a bad idea there are ideas that
the audience might not enjoy and might
not be feasible for us to produce but I
want to hear anything that comes to mind
what segments is missing from the David
Pakman show that you would like to see
added because this is one of those
opportunities where we change the format
of the show and I want to hear from you
david at david pakman.com what should we
replace audience questions with